our main story tonight concerns the past
week's terrible events in Missouri an
officer shot an 18 year-old man outside
an apartment complex in Ferguson
Missouri it is unclear at this hour what
led to the shooting but witnesses say
the teenager was unarmed angry
confrontations between protesters and
police in riot gear the same anger and
outrage that exploded into a chaotic
night of looting and violence this whole
story is depressingly familiar and there
are so many unanswered questions
regarding why an officer would shoot an
unarmed teenager what is absolutely
clear is that the police have handled
everything since then terribly and the
tone-deafness
began with this asked how many times
Brown was shot st. Louis County Police
Chief Jon Belmar said it was more than
just a couple but I don't think it was
many more than that just just think
about what he's saying there not much
more than more than twice don't you try
and minimize this anymore
look listen everyone only very many more
than one bullet was fired so everybody
calm down shall we
the police then refused four days to
release the name of the officer involved
and when they eventually did they
packaged it with a DVD extra that no one
wanted at the same time they released
video of Michael Brown allegedly
carrying out a store robbery minutes
before he was shot and killed and that
has sparked new outrage yeah of course
it has because it's irrelevant
if the police wanted to distract
everyone with a video that has
absolutely nothing to do with Michael
Brown shooting they should have just
released Ghostbusters instead it's
exactly as relevant to everything that
happened afterwards but but the more the
week went on the more you got the sense
that those in charge in Ferguson don't
have the best sense of how their
community feels just listen to the mayor
we've never seen this kind of violence
we've never seen this kind of
frustration or tension between the races
I've always been proud to say that to
people
I know we've always gotten along and I
know our communities still gets along
well Oh we're absolutely famous for it
presumably that is why I the mayor of
Ferguson I'm currently on national
television presumably we're
talking about how well our town is
getting along right now and always has
the thing is if you ask around in
Ferguson you get a slightly different
story the Carson resume is frequently
it's all through the day is all to the
night then they not beating us
physically they doing it verbally here's
the thing the mayor doesn't understand
that as a general rule not one should
ever be allowed to say there is no
history of racial tension here because
that sentence has never been true
anywhere on earth there is tension
between emperor penguins and gentle
penguins cute Gentoo penguins flapping
over here stealing our fish not you
chinstrap penguins you're cool you
you've got you got as a good at math so
so which one of these two men is right
about what life as a young
african-american in Ferguson is like
well too much of that let's look at the
police force what does it look like in a
town which is about two-thirds
african-american what does the makeup of
your police force the number and how
many of them are white I just want
clarification of that I mean they keep
saying three of our three are
african-american but that actually
believe it's five there was six but one
left fairly recently we also have a
Hispanic and two Asian Pacific Islanders
exactly it doesn't stop bad guys we got
a couple of white guys who occasionally
listen to hip-hop music I mean
Macklemore sure but still
also also we have six Norwegian
Americans who really enjoyed the Lion
King on Broadway so it's like it's more
diverse than it seems but despite the
presence of both of the Pacific
Islanders and of course the Hispanic
let's not forget him the Ferguson Police
do seem to target minorities 86% of
police stops are african-americans 92%
of police searches nearly 93% of arrests
even though they stopped more blacks
more White's had contraband yeah of
course more White's had contraband they
knew that if you look like this you
don't get stopped if you are white in
Ferguson you would need to be snorting
cocaine directly off your dashboards to
get stopped by the police whereas if
you're an african-american in Ferguson
like say Henry Davis here you may have a
slightly different experience because
while in custody in the Ferguson Jail in
2009 officers grabbed him and pushed him
and struck him multiple times they say
they were provoked although oddly there
is no video of this incident despite the
fact that jail is equipped with video
cameras and what is known though at this
point is that he was later charged with
four counts of destruction of city
property for bleeding on their uniforms
and I've got to say he was lucky that he
wasn't eating spaghetti at the time of
his beating well they would have
upgraded that charge to a felony and
that is just a local police the County
police also have had their share of
problems a st. Louis County police
lieutenant is without a job tonight he
was fired for allegedly ordering patrol
officers to arrest black people shopping
in South County oh it wasn't just that
he ordered racial profiling it was how
he allegedly did it with his colleagues
claiming that he said things like let's
have a black day and let's make the jail
cells more colorful now let's be fair
let's be fair here let's have a black
day is an awesome thing to say if you
are shaft
and let's make the jail cells more
colorful is entirely appropriate if
you're an interior designer with a
folder full of paint swatches however if
you're a white police officer it's not
ideal to say either of those which is
not to say that all cops are bad they
are clearly not also the people of
Ferguson wants and need an effective
police force but perhaps their
relationship was best summed up by this
photo from earlier this week
not just ludicrously aggressive police
facing off against an unarmed man but
also the fact that someone has clearly
written to the police on the postbox
something something apparently CNN did
not notice when they were using this
photo during all of their coverage now
you might also notice in that photo that
the police are troublingly dressed like
they're about to launch an assault on
Fallujah well it turns out that that is
no coincidence since 1996 in response to
the war on drugs a Department of Defense
transferred 4.3 billion dollars in
military equipment to local and state
police after 9/11 the Department of
Homeland Security made additional
equipment available to local law
enforcement through federal funds for
terrorism prevention that's right and
this has happened on such a scale that
it enabled small towns like Keene New
Hampshire to apply for a Bearcat a
military-grade armored personnel truck
which they needed because as their
application argued the terrorism threat
is far-reaching and often unforeseen and
cited as a possible target their annual
Pumpkin Festival
specifically this pumpkin festival which
is now being protected by vixx good luck
easily outmaneuvering that teenagers
with baseball bats and if you're
wondering what it feels like to have a 9
resistant vehicle on the streets of your
town I give you a YouTube video of two
dudes from Saginaw Michigan holy
dude super armor dude doesn't anybody
seem in there dude you can't even see
them looks cool dude they go look up big
these tires are compared are it's taller
than its dude to be fair to be fair that
is exactly how they reacted when a
Chipotle first opened there but the
point is listen carefully as one of them
suddenly realizes something
[Music]
here's the thing no it hasn't got that
bad because unless you live in downtown
Kabul there is no practical need for
anything like that in your town just ask
the people that it came from the army
itself actually in a newsletter a few
months ago recommended against using em
raps even at US military bases you know
on paved streets in the United States
they're actually unsafe they tear up the
streets they have a high rollover
potential exactly the only vehicle that
should be tearing up the streets of
Saginaw is Chad souped up Honda Civic
chorus circuited the police are not
soldiers some why in this photo from
Ferguson are they wearing camo
they are northwest of st. Louis not
northwest of the Amazon if they want to
blend in with their surroundings they
should be dressed as a dollar store
where their guns are pointed if you were
actually in the military you would know
that you are not supposed to do that on
the military were trained on something
called escalation of force which
basically means the only time that
you're really going to point a weapon
directly at someone is when you're ready
to pull the trigger and instead of that
we've seen in Ferguson that police are
just wandering around with their weapons
up at all times pointing them at people
that obviously didn't pose a threat well
what they don't currently pose a threat
but you know it's really all about what
they might do now they could for
instance during the police be given a
gun they're not trained to use properly
and then wander around pointing it at
people that would be terrifying
the points at the pointer is 0.8 if you
are a cop in the United States you
should dress for the job you have not
the job you want because if you have all
this equipment it's going to go to your
head look at Doraville Georgia
population 8,500 the police there got a
tank a while back and up until a few
days ago this video was on the front
page of their website
[Applause]
the name of that song is and this is
true die die and it was a
good choice because believe me that
video does not pair well with Simon &
Garfunkel now that video was just a
training exercise but the problem is
police departments don't just use this
stuff for training thanks in part to
this kind of access to military hardware
there has been a massive rise in both
the number and the use of Police
Department's SWAT teams the number of
SWAT raids have gone up by fourteen
hundred percent since the 1980s an
estimated 50,000 now take place every
year
just keep that clip in mind when I tell
you that 79 percent of SWAT deployments
are now for executing search warrants
and most of those were for drug
investigations so yes if you are getting
high in your dorm room right now you are
not paranoid there is a SWAT team
outside and they are coming to get you
all of which all of which brings us back
to this week and to Ferguson so how do
you improve things there well you could
demilitarize the police force to stop
things looking like this but that would
just change the optics the substance of
the problem would still be there as was
embodied by a police officer on the
streets of Ferguson this week who was
dressed entirely normally the phrase
bring it you animals is barely
acceptable during a zoo escape it's not
even acceptable in the restaurant in
Mary Poppins where penguins are waiters
brilliant you've in animal like don't
treat them like that that they'll piss
on your suit that they'll pissing
yourself and you'll deserve it that kind
of statement betrays an inability to see
the citizens of Ferguson as individuals
and instead treats them as a threatening
whole and that is a top-down problem
because last night this is how the
governor of Missouri decided to try and
rebuild trust between the police and the
community
I signed in order to clearing a state of
emergency an Ori implementation of a
curfew and he apparent in the impact and
a curfew in the impacted area furthest
in a perfect so you took a community
tired of being treated as criminals and
imprisoned them all in their own houses
for a night and in doing so employed the
tone of a pissed-off vice-principal
trying to restore order at an assembly
if we're going to achieve justice
we must first have and maintain peace
this is a test the eyes of the euro are
watching that is profoundly patronizing
look let's see if you can all remain
quiet for 20 minutes and then we'll see
if you can all go and play outside if
even the governor can't distinguish
between the good and the bad elements of
the community and decided to punish
everyone equally then that should go
both ways I know the police love their
ridiculous unnecessary military
equipment so here's another patronizing
test let's take it all away from them
and if they can make it through a whole
month without killing a single unarmed
black man then and only then can they
get their toys back
[Applause]